[Music]
big trees are made of leaves who am I to
disagree
check out pink celebrating all things
fall on The Tonight Show last night
here's the deal she can sing anything so
talented first album in five years
beautiful trauma is out now and while
penis family portrait seems perfect
she tells Michelle Turner she's all too
familiar with the struggles of every
working mom I want my kids to see what
it looks like to have a mom that's a
boss I want to be the best mom in the
world I put way too much pressure on
myself that's how we've mom now it's
just never good enough but pink is
thankful her Rockstar schedule allows
her kids
six-year-old Willow at nine month old
Jameson to travel the world with her
[Music]
how proud of your mommy are you I'm like
how does she have this mom guilt cuz
look at this little girl huh obviously
you were her heroine because no matter
what you just it's not good enough
issued good big sister
yes really she likes him now that he can
laugh she likes him she thought he was
very boring and annoying at one point
she looked at me and said I never
thought I'd have to beg you for a cuddle
with crocodile tears in her eyes I was
like oh did that kill you yeah yeah took
about six months oh my channelling that
pain into art pink seventh studio album
beautiful trauma is out today
[Music]
beautiful trauma I love it and I'm angry
or it came from I look at my husband who
is this beautiful man
who's covered in scars and every scar is
just it's an incredible story of intense
trauma that he's survived
pinked husband of 11 years his former
motocross racer Carey Hart and he has
been her musical muse through thick and
thin you said it in an article you don't
hand your your wedding ring back I feel
like we've come a long way this is why I
used to throw it I think I threw it in
the pool once saying to all of his
friends I'll never see you again have a
nice butt
he's a good man he is any super kids
[Music]